[Musique]
frais moins confiance à une femme
15 on a regardé les fictions diffusées
sur les chaînes historiques mais toutes
les fictions donc ça veut dire aussi
bien les unitaires donc les longs
métrages de cinéma
une partie des téléfilms que les
scieries c'est à dire les séries donc
télévisée et puis une autre partie des
téléfilms ce qui est entre dans des
collections c'est quelque chose qui
n'avait jamais été fait de manière aussi
précise ce qu'on tire de cette étude
c'est que sur la période 2008-2010 8 on
est à 12 % de réalisatrice pour les
programmes diffusés 12% s'est pas
beaucoup c'est la moyenne sur cette
période là en réalité au quand on
regarde plus précisément on passe de 10
à 15 % 10 % au total en 2008 15% en 2018
il ya clairement des chaînes qui ont
très bien progressé
par exemple tf1 et france 2 connaissent
une augmentation impressionnante de leur
taux de réalisatrice dans les fictions
diffusées entre 2008 et 2018 il ya des
chaînes par contre il reconnaît une
évolution en baisse notamment m6
ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'entre 2008
et 2018 il ya de moins en moins deux
longs métrages de cinéma programmé à la
télévision il ya aussi de moins en moins
de téléfilms qui ne rentrent pas dans
une collection de l'autre côté il y à
une augmentation du nombre de séries
diffusées à la télévision et ils gagnent
en parallèle de plus en plus de
réalisatrice dans les séries notamment
il ya josée dayan pour la série captain
marleau sur france 3 qui est un succès
d'audience
donc c'est une augmentation certes
notable mais elle n'est pas non plus
formidable
l'équipe de la recherche de li na s'est
intéressé à un échantillon des 54 milles
programmes concernés par l'étude sur les
réalisatrices et a déterminé que les
femmes avaient 35 % du temps de parole
totale c'est-à-dire qu'elle parle
presque deux fois moins que les
personnages masculins
[Musique]
effectivement il ya des différences dans
le temps de parole des femmes à l'écran
dans les fictions selon la composition
de l'équipe derrière la caméra on
observe que lorsque ce sont uniquement
des hommes qui sont la réalisation les
femmes par le moins que lorsque il n'ya
que des femmes à réalisation ou lorsque
l'équipe est mixte
ces soupçons de misogynie ou de sexisme
stéréotypes de genre sont revenues à
plusieurs reprises dans les interviews
tout le monde dans l'étude l'évoquent
d'une manière ou d'une autre avec des
baux plus ou moins fort avec des
formules plus ou moins détournés
[Musique]
c'est une solution qui est revendiqué
qui est partagée qui est défendue par
plusieurs des personnes interrogées dans
l'étude mais qui pour certaines autres
n'est pas la panacée ce qui ressort de
la étude c'est que du côté des
producteurs
du côté des scénaristes aussi du côté
des personnes concernées les
réalisatrices mais aussi du côté des
chaînes il ya un désir de changement qui
est assez claire
[Musique]